hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreigner again and
today we have some interesting news to
talk about today we have some new
ornaments double xp the season 8 state
of balance and the content of the week
which is everybody's favorite so as
light as likely be if you do enjoy now
let's get started today's video so first
up is the new ornaments a lot of people
have been messaging me on discord in
Twitter talking about the new ornaments
and actually no clue what they were
talking about until I then hopped onto
for honor and realize that there's
actually new ornaments in the game if
you have some type of outstanding
relationship within the community it's
not like a youtuber only thing I think
majority of the playerbase has it
because as long as you're not being
reported or leaving games early I
believe you do get it and it's available
on all character so if you do have the
ornament you can go check it and I
believe it should be there by now I
think it's been out for like a couple
weeks so far on top of that I believe
double xp is starting this weekend I
believe it's February 22nd to the 24th
so if you do want to go play some double
xpeke and use black prior gained some
reps on him use an old hero goods to
prep 70 anything like that definitely
try to utilize it this weekend and get a
lot of reps next up was the season 8
state of balance and they basically
compared dual breach and Dominion versus
its full population versus plat and
higher we're also looking at the tier
list made by the competitive owner
subreddit and kind of looking at the
numbers and giving their thoughts so
this is the picture on screen is going
to be the season 8 state of balance for
everyone who played in season 8 in
plating duel so this is every single
person as long as you had one rep or
higher on your main account on the left
is the characters and on the right is
the respective overall win rate for
example the top 5 characters and there
are JJ can say Orochi Valkyrie in
Shaolin with the bottom characters being
gladiator Highlander Nobu XI warlord and
PK which is pretty interesting to see
and now if we take that and instead of
having everyone in the population we
just think the people that are platinum
rank and higher it's a little bit
different top 5 is consisting of every
single woman character and conquer with
the bottom stove being about the same
with a slightly mixed up order this is
pretty interesting to see cuz now every
single woman is now in the top five with
conquer as well whereas before it wasn't
all of them they were kind of toward the
bottom or in the average which AJ of
course being at the top now these big
numbers in the middle can look pretty
deceiving but they're basically
percentages so
look in the top-left it says for example
when JJ who's on the Left fights of T on
dnt on DS name is at the top when JJ
fights at T on D he wins 60% of the
matches which means when T on D fights a
GG he will win 40% that's basically what
it means so interesting wants to know is
that peacekeeper has 25 gladiator has 27
and no blue she has 29% all against JJ
which is really interesting to see for a
character that seems like he's
absolutely crazy in for befores and not
really that great in duels
JJ's definitely shown up in season 8 and
prove that he can do lots of damage in
duels now this might just be because of
his wonky animations and the fact that
he does so much damage I'm not entirely
sure actually but it is still pretty
interesting to note that they have a
very low percentage against him next now
is the pic rate for duel so this is
gonna be a little bit different this has
nothing to do based off one percentages
how many people could pick the character
based on a percentage written is gonna
be at the top of 11% with Orochi and
Centurion following and shougo key
warlord and new sha are at the bottom
with 2% and this was for everybody the
same is said for platinum and higher but
there's a little bit of a slight shuffle
but nothing too major this is what
concerns me though is because in season
eight warlord actually is s tier in the
competitive foreigner subreddit now the
only reason he's actually considered s
tier is just because of his out of
stairs out of guard crashing charge move
that is the only thing really that keeps
him at s tier because if he's fighting
locked then he's basically gonna lose so
I'm actually really impressed that there
isn't many people that have picked
warlord in duels now that just good the
2% is probably the competitive players
and stuff and then maybe a few people
who are just really good at warlord but
it's still interesting to see we're
gonna breeze through Dominion real quick
and show off the win rate Orochi shinobi
shougo ki gladiator in PK are at the
bottom of the win rate with JJ ARA Musha
raider ken SE and lob ringer which is
pretty surprising to be at the top for
platinum ranking above it's basically
the same except while bringer got pushed
down a little bit and shaman and Nobu
she kind of took a spot going up of its
let's and just think and for breach JJ
ARA mushiya Centurion Nisha and Raider
are at the top with peacekeeper shougo
ki Orochi warlord and shinobi being at
the bottom no she seems to be performing
way better in breach than in Dominion
it's interesting because assassins have
a lot more trouble than the static art
heroes and for
four modes yet anusha is third I think
it's our caltrops personally to be
honest because they're pretty good at
minions and of course slowing down an
opponent in a group fight this this
seems pretty obvious though JJ and Rader
at the top cuz a good minion clears and
stuff like that the pic rate is very
similar to the win rate except warden is
still at the very top buffer platen
higher the Wulin covered just about
every single section in the top five
except musiah whose are on the bottom
this is very interesting to see cuz it
seems like new Shah has a low pick rate
but a very high win rate which is very
interesting to see and Shaolin and
tianyu the exact opposite high pick
rates but average win rates I actually
have no clue what the whole point of
this is maybe just the few people that
do play Musha are absolute gods at her
or something or something else is going
on with these other characters lunar
your thoughts on that one member this is
the season 8 state of balance so this is
right around the time that the Wulin
were added so black prior was not
involved in this
the warlord and the peak a slight buffs
were not added as well so that was not
taken to account that'll be starting in
the season nine state advantage which
we'll probably know a lot more about
once the debt has been recovered for
next season and also they're gonna be
coming out with a midseason patch which
will come next month kind of like the
mid-season reinforcements for Rainbow
six it's basically a nice little sweet
patch in between every season and they
said that they were gonna be doing one
every single season throughout the whole
year and one of the main things that
they're gonna be looking into is giving
a longer cooldown time for the soothing
mist for JJ because it comes back pretty
quickly
shinobi's gonna get a nerf to his out of
lock move the slide tackle but they will
compensate by giving him a faint able
zone so that's interesting to see
centurion does not yet have a faint
Apple zone so maybe he'll get one soon
but it's nice to see that one of these
two guys is finally getting it cuz it's
been long overdue on top of that they're
also gonna be lookin at revenge changes
such as when you're at a 1v1 and then
that random teammate of yours comes up
and smacks the dude one time and how he
instantly has revenge I'm gonna be
looking into that and trying to fix that
a lot more and then lastly to end the
video they have the battle outfits for
the content of the week everyone's
favorite content
everyone loves battle outfits be
crawling critters ocean sensation and
thorn Hardt is gonna be the Battle of it
so I'm actually not gonna lie these do
look pretty cool probably not gonna buy
them but if anything I'd probably buy
the crawling critters I like the orange
and the red to it so if you do want to
get that you can buy right now this
shouldn't be too big on Stila better off
it's our usual Ichi
anyway hey guys it's gonna be the end of
the Viets I hope you guys did enjoy let
me know thoughts on the season 8 state
of balance they should have a blog post
going up later tonight so and that was a
whole controversy from like last season
or two seasons ago when people were all
over the place with that but if they
happen to showcase some new things or
talk about things that they didn't talk
about that are worth noting
I'll definitely making another video
later tonight so just be on the lookout
for that if it happens to come out big
eyes like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here updates
patch notes and leaks if you want to be
kept updated with everything happening
in the world of for honor and never want
to miss an update definitely stay
subscribe to the channel but that guy's
my two most recent videos will be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out and I guys hope you agree today
thank for watching the video enjoy the
rest of your day and peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]